denise make a good point though people
take it for granted about how fast it
happens
so we want to give this warning and get
that expert advice before the weekend
and before the heat right because we
were talking about this now we didn't
get get acclimated to it right so we go
from the 70s right to the hundreds right
so of course that is going to be an
issue for people prepare for follow the
advice you just heard in that interview
great advice from them right so got to
keep that in mind drink lots of water
here's a deal if you're already starting
to get uh lightheaded it's already
almost too late because you just didn't
have enough water all right so keep that
in mind live look outside from our tower
cam at black mountain looking towards
the las vegas strip got some clouds
overhead i'm checking up on the pollen
report
because we're all against sniffling the
sneezing it's just been an issue this
season with the winds and the dust
ragweed olive and grasses moderate
readings still high but not the higher
unhealthy readings right so that's still
up there air quality good good to see
that here's your weekend forecast now as
we dive into the weekend no pun intended
96 degrees on saturday 100 on sunday
that will be our first triple digit day
since september it has been that long
and it's in the forecast hot and sunny
on saturday we'll see a bit of a breeze
those gusts up to 20 not too bad but
then on sunday it will become breezy
again and hot there's your gusts between
20 to 30 miles per hour your temperature
trend shows that day the hottest day in
the eight day forecast with temperatures
still elevated on monday and notice we
start to see a downward trend in those
numbers as we get through next week so
we hit the century mark and then start
to see those numbers drop how much above
average are we for this time of year on
sunday that 100 degree temperature is
way above normal this is where we should
be for this time in may we're going to
hit that century mark for sure on sunday
maybe as early as saturday throughout
many of our neighborhoods 58 degrees
overnight increasing clouds cool morning
but we'll decrease those clouds by early
morning tomorrow 89 degrees plenty of
sunshine warmer and calm tomorrow look
at that now we'll be
slightly above average many of our
neighborhoods will be in those high 80s
some of you touching in the 90s without
the far east side nellis sunrise manor
green valley whitney ranch included the
86 for prom triple digits for you death
valley 98 in laughlin here is your eight
day forecast we showed you those highs
reaching the century mark on sunday with
some clouds look at that and then next
week another system dives in brings us
more wind but look at this we drop back
to the high 80s next week
that is your most accurate forecast
we'll send it back to you